[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
it's
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she
[Music]
so
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
no check this out
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome to
gamespot
gamescom pre-show i'm lucy james joined
today by tomorrow hussein
lose your shirt lose your pants
so sorry we already just sprung that old
game trailers uh
uh song on you there but honestly it's a
classic and it gets us very high for
gamescom
gamescom doing things very differently
this year ordinarily we would be
in the kiln messer in lovely cologne
germany um
hiding from the hordes because it is a
very very busy trade show
uh on the floor of the business center
that is actually what
happens because it's like what 300 000
people
too many people too many people some
would say but it's always like a really
fun show and i
personally i'm very sad it's not
happening this year but it's all moving
online
uh jeff keely is doing his gamescom
opening night
live very very shortly so after our
pre-show you can go over to jeff's
pre-show
and then watch the extravaganza it's
gonna be
two hours long or so uh plenty of
announcements and
exclusives so let's get excited about it
let's talk about
what we know we're gonna see at the show
because jeff has been teasing
some of these reveals on twitter so i've
got a list here let's work our way down
let's start with star wars
squadrons we've got a world premiere new
look not long until that game
launches tam cali which of you more
excited for this one
well it'll probably make me motion sick
so probably
i mean yeah i i'm the jury's still out
on whoever i was going to throw up in
the cockpit of a star wars
fighter but i'm i'm definitely excited
to i think i'm like
i'm getting caught up in the infectious
hype for it mostly because
one rob handler is very very excited
about that stuff he gets
uh like hyped about star wars in a way
that i wish i could get hyped about
star wars but i can't i wouldn't get
hyped about anything yeah
i like to i like to feed off of him like
some sort of hype vampire
but i'm interested to see what they show
um i think we might get a little more
like story stuff
i feel like the last trailer we got was
a pretty good um
first of all he like look at you know
this is legit
gameplay-wise it looks cool we did a
preview uh straight after which rob
actually took on um and there's like a
video uh
on on youtube and on site that kind of
is pretty good at explaining why that
game is interesting and why it could be
a legit good star wars like
uh fighter experience um but the story
part of it is still what's kind of a
mystery right now
and they've done vague information about
where it's kind of set and some of the
players that are in
in kind of the narrative but i'm excited
to see more
of the story itself to hook people in
give it that emotional kind of
anchor for everyone which in turn will
make you know
rob take his trousers off and do weird
things which is exciting
what well i i took a turn
i know i i i too am i feed off of rob's
hype for this game i've always loved
star wars video
games i i did do the um i forget what
it's called with the the ride at
disneyland
and i had to close my eyes the whole
time so i'm like not sure i'll be able
to play it
but um i've always loved star wars video
games so i'm really excited and i'm
i'm intrigued is it do we know if it's a
canon story do we even know that
are you assuming all the stuff now is
because ever since they wiped the slate
clean with the old stuff
um but no i'm i'm a great i i'm excited
for this one
purely because playing x-men versus tie
fighter some of my favorite memories
from being a kid i love those modes in
battlefront
um that's you know my multiplayer mode
of choice there so
um yeah i'm time to see more squadrons
um we have a lot of games to go through
so let's wake down the list um
probably not going to touch too uh long
on a brand new animated series for
blizzard uh all about warcraft uh
afterlives
i will say like they they make they make
them coolest like cinematic sentences
in the business if even a small amount
of that
transfers over to this animated series
which i assume it would it will be it's
going to be interesting it's going to be
amazing i'm surprised that it's taken
them this long to turn
warcraft into some sort of animated
series it's
perfect for it they've got literally
years worth of material
um to do this so i'm excited for this
yeah me too
i'm just i'm sad it's not overwatch
though give it time
if this works everyone watch this so
that we can eventually get a
overwatch and maybe even a starcraft one
i love that
and if you call it an anime tomorrow and
i will fight you
it's not an anime it's not anime but it
does look cool
it's an anime tid series yes
there you go uh we also have new
announcements from spellbreak
um electrifying announcements allegedly
um
i i still haven't tried spellbreak but i
know michael hym on our side uh played a
bit of it and he was kind of stoked for
it so
yeah i might give it a go i'm a huge fan
of electricity so i'm up this
i mean sure i mean bloodborne
electricity
yeah worst favorite things two things
yeah you can't have one without the
other
that's true speaking of people who can
really get you hyped michael hyam is
another one
michael heights man yes
um all right moving on from spellbreak
to mafia so
uh for a little bit of context we're
actually shooting this on wednesday just
a little bit ahead of time
um and so there have been a bunch of
videos in an embargo
about mafia which has gone uh live today
i'm really really hyped for mafia i
never played the game
uh when it first came out in 2002 played
mafia 3
um for its sins because that was one
buggy as hell game but mafia i'm like
and also because of michael hype
man i am now playing yakuza and like
controlling parts
of uh tokyo and i'm just like
okay but like what if i did this in a
different setting in a different place
so i'm very excited to
do more of that i'm fully becoming just
a crime boy now
i played the original mafia when it came
out on pc and it was a lot of fun
also one of those weird games where if
you break the traffic rules you get in
trouble
in a quite aggressive way and coming
from grand theft auto you're like
i don't need to stop for this red light
you do need to stop with the red light
stop for the red lights
and i'm really interested to see what
they do with the uh the
like the formula one style mission which
was
100 broken and it was like close to
impossible on pc
and it was so bad that they introduced
like an option to skip it later but i
did it pre-skip
so i think that's one of my greatest
gaming achievements um
completing that absolutely abysmal
racing level
before it got patched out because it was
basically unplayable
i was going to say because wasn't it
built for a a wheel or something
steering wheels yeah
but it was like i i still have
flashbacks it's like ptsd playing that
honestly well we're proud of you thank
you
i'm one of those people that actually
does follow traffic
as to the best of my ability in gta
um because i you know i i have problems
and um so i'm actually really excited
i've never played mafia
um and i it's one of those games that
i've always wanted to return to and i
i always like when a game gets
definitive edition or remastered
because it's like an opportunity to
revisit it without having to go back to
those janky moments
so i'm excited to learn more yeah me too
and it was weird because until three
came along mafia was never really on my
radar at all insane
um i didn't realize what a big deal it
was but now like i was pouring over the
footage from definitive edition
and i was like oh yeah yeah this is it
this is two years two is also good yeah
i'm excited i'm genuinely excited i
think this year because it's been
such a strange year of everyone staying
indoors i've been finally picking up the
franchises that i've kind of
passed me by hence my playing yakuza
right now
um but before this becomes a yakuza fan
cast
let's move on uh big reveals from
destiny to beyond light which is the
next expansion
um cali i know you're a big destiny
player you were a big destiny player
is beyond like gonna bring you back um
i'm very intrigued by it i
because you know a big part of beyond
light is retiring that old content to
make room for
new content i mean it's destiny 2 has
become massive since its release
and there's you know like i was never a
big raider i mean i've done the raids
but like
that was never i just like i love the
shooting and destiny i like kind of the
the loop i find it relaxing and i really
like to gambit
so there's like specific things i really
like and then and
things that i never that never really
mattered to me and a lot of those things
are being retired so like the leviathan
raids being retired
actually a lot of the raids are um a lot
of exotic quests that i've already
completed thank goodness
um so i i'm intrigued at like feeling
feeling a little bit oh my god i was
gonna say feeling lighter but
the pun was not intended um feeling
feeling less pressure to complete all of
those
old quests and braids and and
doing all of that and being able to
start fresh because i do feel like i've
gotten so behind
in the months since i i kind of lapsed
playing destiny 2.
um but i
the thing that intrigues me a lot
actually is the
new like uh elemental power
stasis don't know anything about that
i hope we learn more about that because
i'm kind of curious like we know a lot
about what's retiring
um about like the setting we know some
of the setting of
europa the icy tundra
and oh and that's another thing because
like a lot of locations are getting
retired so there's
there's a lot that we know that's going
away i want to learn more about what's
coming so
stasis is one of those like i play
hunter so
i want to hear how that works into
hunter abilities
i want to hear what my jumps gonna be i
love my
my double jump my triple jump so um
yeah i guess i guess for a destiny
player you do want to get those like
granular details a lot of the time
um that's not really the gamescom's not
really the place for granular granular
stuff that's usually like on bungie's
blog
um but i'm expecting some mood setting
uh hopefully i don't kill any characters
this time
uh that would be nice they killed their
best character for some reason i'm still
upset
um but yeah i it's it's interesting it's
definitely interesting
tam i know you played a bunch of destiny
too as well are you going to get back in
yeah i think i'm probably going to jump
back in it's been a long time since i
got into it i'm interested to see how
they
approach like vaulting content because
like kelly said that's the main thing
that they want to do
but i wonder if it's purely based on
what's being played
versus what's not being played that much
or if there's an element of can we
streamline this so
when we launch on ps5 and xbox series x
the content that's in there
is like the best stuff that will get
newcomers on board and streamline them
through the
process to get um to the you know
endgame stuff i
imagine that would be the smart thing to
do without kind of
you know creating new skus and
fundamentally overhauling the entire
game just to snip out the bits that
might be like
uh fatty and make it a bit more leaner
as an experience so i hope that is the
case one because
i kind of want to power through a lot of
that stuff again and get kind of up to
speed but two because i think it would
be more interesting
they've talked about how this is they're
doing this instead of destiny three
so as part of destiny 3 they would have
i imagine
you know created some sort of
on-boarding process and you know bring
new players in
so i think they need to retrofit that
element of it somewhat into
um new light and i hope they do do that
dude yeah
do you do no i i'm the same like i
played a bunch of jessie too on launch
and because i
lapsed with it i just feel so out of the
loop
and so i feel like this is probably the
best time for me to jump back in and i'm
excited to see
more of stasis as well just a little bit
of variety
um so let's move on from destiny uh like
i said we're recording this on wednesday
so we don't actually know what call of
duty has revealed today
um i mean we know that it's called gt
black ops cold war
there's gonna be another look at it um
in opening night live
i'm like cautiously optimistic about
cod blocks cow sorry anyone from
activision
who's probably hating that acronym
already but
call of duty black ops was like my card
and
this is gonna be i know this is a direct
sequel to card uh two blobs one
which is just gave me all kinds of
excited don't know if they're gonna be
bringing back like
some of the fun like our favorite
characters from that game but
like woods or i don't even remember what
happened in mason at the end reznov
well no because i think because like
didn't he kind of he maybe died but
maybe it was a figment of your
imagination
who knows but i am definitely excited to
see more from uh black ops cold war
guys uh i know we'll play card here
are you excited for this new one i think
by the time this goes up there will be a
bunch of content available on
hit video game website gamespot.com
call of duty black ops cal um so
if you've somehow missed the trailers uh
go there and on youtube.com
gamespot you'll find the trailers and
anything else there as well as a bunch
of
uh articles around the game what it
involves so you can read up about that
stuff but yeah i'm excited for it
i'm super excited for i hope that the uh
a black ops cow becomes like a fan
creation
in the community and becomes a big deal
i'd love to see this cow dressed in like
stealth outfits and doing like
uh secret war crimes or whatever later
that's all right that's how reznoff
comes back like he's got the beard
yeah it's gary oldman as a cow
uh yeah but i'm excited to see what they
do the black ops series has always been
narratively my favorite of the bunch i
think
no one's gonna be like holy [ __ ] that's
a take but it's
it's you know most people they do at
least interesting things
while also denying that they're making
any political statement which i'm sure
they'll continue to do this year but
we'll see how that goes
yeah i i mean i really like
the black ops series for some reason i
played a ton of black ops 3 multiplayer
and i got really into warzone there's
just like little things i
pick and choose from black ops but i
think the storytelling is really
interesting i really wish they would
commit like black ops 3 like almost
talked about ptsd and then shied away
from it
um but it sounds like like maybe there
will be more
story things but the thing about the
cold war right is that it's called that
because of the lack of actual conflict
so i find that really intriguing i want
to know more about how that actually
works
um and you know like i
i i get fatigued on call of duty and
then it brings me back
you know that you you guys know how that
goes like
you're like oh yeah stay frosty but then
you're kind of like
no i'm gonna play for several hours
tonight and it's gonna be a time
so there's a lot that i'm really
intrigued by and i i also really like
war zone
and i kind of want to see how that
factors in i know
like we understand that war zone is part
of the announcement or
has been coming at you from the past but
um
i i found like i really like slow battle
royale so there's
there's like i said there's elements
from different black ops games that like
i hope make an appearance in cold war
um but the main thing i want to know is
how
the actual cold war factors into
how the combat works in this game
because just coming at it from a
historical perspective is just an
interesting title
if you really want to get nitpicky about
it so
all right let's move on doom eternal so
the ancient gods
part one uh which is a campaign
expansion for doom eternal came out this
year
this year has felt well like it's gone
on for an eternal amount of time
i didn't like honestly it was the very
definition of eternal doom 2020
i genuinely when i was like looking at
all the announcements and stuff that um
have been teased for
opening night live i was like oh my god
do maternal was this year
um so oh god yeah
it was march it was the same day as
animal crossing
um so to put my cards on the table um i
never finished do eternal because
honestly i was at a point where it was a
bit too stressful for me because
everything else is going on but i did
really enjoy it and actually because of
the accessibility options i could play
this one
uh unlike doom 2016 which i couldn't
apply because it gave me intense motion
sickness
um ancient gods though i was watching
like the little teaser trailer it does
look very interesting
i don't know if it's enough to get me to
go back into doom though
um did either of you guys play eternal
time i know you
did a bit on xbox yeah so i had the xbox
version i played that and it made me
feel a bit sick but i just recently got
the pc
version so i'm gonna hop into that
because there's a little more like um
features that you can mess with to
reduce motion sickness so i'm gonna try
that but i'm excited to know that
after because i liked what i played
mostly i felt like it was
perhaps overreaching and what it needed
to do to be a bit
the levels were very very long yeah very
long
and unnecessarily elaborate like i feel
like
i'm not going to say like they they
don't understand what made the original
version of like not version of doom but
last time they released the the new
demon reboot good but like what i liked
about it was like
short sharp punchy like incredibly high
octane
um sequences action sequences
and now i'm like do i really need to be
swinging from a
a pole and trying to double jump across
the mouths of hell
i'm just like uh i could do without that
stuff but
once it gets into the actual fighting
and the combat and the uh kind of that
movement it's really cool so
knowing that there's more of that out
there and i do love the melodramatic
like
hell [ __ ] that is constantly doing yeah
um
yeah yeah so it it speaks to your goth
soul
a little bit it does yeah it does i i do
like the intelligence of like
figuring out what kind of kills to do to
get health versus ammo
i think there's like like i found that
really
mentally taxing almost which so i also
didn't finish do maternal
as you guys know i've been playing
animal crossing uh
obsessively so that's the main reason
not actually
it's not actually do maternal's fault
but um i
i do i like when expansions and stuff
come out because they do give me a
an excuse to go back i kind of feel like
i have to justify going back to games
that i
i missed um for work reasons so that'll
definitely get me to check it out again
um but but yeah maybe the the level
design will be a little bit
less uh bloated it's not the right word
but
a little less intensive yeah uh moving
on we've got
the game that has taken quarantine by
storm
for guys so it'll be details about
season two
um with season one should end i think
roughly early october
so i'm like and today they announced
that they've had seven million players
i'm very very excited four guys is like
i don't know if takeshi's castle was
really a thing in america but like
in the uk it was always on a channel
called dave late at night
you'd always watch tikash's castle yeah
we haven't we have an entire tv
challenge called dave
because i mean everyone knows a dave so
that's that's that slogan but takeshi's
castle
was like just just the the comedy of
people falling over
it's why i'm subscribed to our slash
children falling over
because you can't beat it and so four
guys very much uh captures that for me
i'm very excited to see some new maps
please no more team games
no new team games please i i think if if
this season they don't
introduce private lobbies and do like
the
the uh um thing where you can like
create a code and let everyone jump in
um like it's it's it's hitting so hard
on streams right now they need to create
a way for people watching a stream to be
like oh i'll jump into this game with
this specific
streamer um i'll be very surprised if
that doesn't happen
very soon oh yeah and i think as well
you've seen the momentum they've had
with getting other developers to
uh put cosmetics in fall guys that
people are jumping at the chance to do
it i wouldn't be surprised if we saw
new collabs maybe being announced or
teased um
but i'm very excited for them i'm very
happy for mediatonic as well
a small uh developer based in the uk and
it four guys has just taken the world by
storm
um fun fact the first one the first
games i reviewed for
uh gamespot as an intern was a
mediatonic game
really i cannot tell you what it was
called it was like
monsters jumping across platforms or
something like that some really old one
oh god we've all come a long way we have
media
[Laughter]
all right we don't have long left before
we go over to the opening night live
pre-show
so well this is the pre-pre-show then
we're gonna go over to jeff's pre-show
um let's talk quickly about ratchet and
clank so it's gonna be an extended ps5
demo
um which is everyone's kind of being
confused about the world premiere aspect
of this one
because it already had a world premiere
back in june at the uh ps5
event but it looked really good and
honestly from the ps5 event it was one
of those games that like
showcased the power of the ps5 in an
interesting way so i'm excited to see
more from it
um cali are you a ratchet clank fan
never played a ratchet and clank i'm
afraid
but you know i am interested in the
power of the ps5
so all right
time oh rachael clank i
great serious um really good platformer
uh especially for playstation like
there's not
a lot of uh that kind of mascot
platformers doing the rounds right now
like we've got mario you've got a little
big planet
there's a new psychoboy thing coming out
i i'm gonna be
very i'm gonna phrase this very
carefully but
little big plan is platforming is
not interested in that one bit uh
like i've done the last
i'm sick to death of subway if i'm
honest like
i could go many years without seeing
sakuya again i'm excited it's coming
back
i think the team behind that game is
really really good um but like
outside of mario like astro bot is the
best platform
in quite some time um but ratchet and
clank always really creative
really interesting i love that they're
they're bringing their game back for the
ps5
i think that's going to be the main
thing there's people out there who are
genuinely just excited to see ratchet
and clank back
they've got a new lombax character um
so that's interesting for a lot of
people but i think a lot of people will
be pouring over the footage to see what
they can extrapolate about the
playstation 5 specifically but still
those games have amazing weapons it's
insomniacs like one of their it plays
insomniac strengths and pre-spider-man
strengths with creativity and that kind
of stuff
and the instant traveling between very
diverse worlds
is is very exciting so i'm excited to
see some more of that
we've only got five or so minutes left
so quickly let's blast through uh the
final
few games that we know are gonna be on
opening night live so
little nightmares too uh was announced
at opening night live last year so we've
got a world
gameplay premiere um i
like tam i remember you going to see
this at gamescom
it was it was really interesting and and
like uh it still is like that original
game is
it's like a little rough around the
edges but like it's a
a fairly small team making it tarzan
studios
but like very very cool game like it's
cheap now if you can find it and check
it out i highly recommend it it's got
that kind of honey i shrunk the kids
vibe to it but also very unsettling and
quite scary at times
gross looking enemies and environments
it's like a short
game but very very cool and i'm excited
to see what
they do with that idea going forward
because that first one was so strong
that i imagine a sequel could be really
really cool
we're also getting a look at uh medal of
honor
above and beyond on what's not called
oculus anymore is it it's called
it's called mark zuckerberg it presents
let me have your data
uh which honestly like i completely even
forgot about this game i went back and
watched the trailer
again probably not one for me i am i do
skew
more cod and battlefield than medal of
honor
um i mean especially now
especially now yeah but i am interested
to see like
how it works in vr and if it yeah i
think it's very reliant on like
uh history and telling accurate war
stories if i remember correctly
um yeah it does have
a unique angle to it at the very least
but like
you can catch a grenade in midair and
throw it back i was going to say it
sounds a little bit intense for vr
and yeah that's what i was afraid of
yeah good intense
i can't wait for like some some parent
to be like oh i want to learn about the
war like relive the old times and stuff
and just be like
i used to throw this grenade and just
blows up in there
all right we've also got a new world
premiere on crash bandicoot 4. it's
about time a game that i am unashamedly
very very excited about
um we've only got a couple of minutes
left but
we've also got lego star wars um a game
that we
it feels like it should have come out
like last year
to kind of tie in with all the rise of
skywalker hype but you know
i'm still i'm still very excited because
lego star wars games are great but
delightful games but let's really let's
end on the game that cali and i are most
excited about
let's give you a new sims 4 game pack
i mean we got university already so that
was like a big one for me but i'm
excited to see what they do
i always love an excuse to play the sims
for eight hours straight
yeah jeff keely in sims put jeff kelly
in sims
is in like a drew carey hey i'm just
coming to this pie
but like you could make him like you can
presumably just put him in your own game
i want i want to see jeff keely in a
recording booth
talking simlish like katy perry during
her thing
but like imagine that like jeff keeley
uh like live show pack where you get all
the stuff needed to put on your own like
live show
like the game awards or wait so like
animal talking
but in yeah yeah and then you can live
there yeah and then you can like it ties
into that old game the movies remember
that
you feel that put yourself in the movie
you put yourself in there and then you
can like invite other sims on to present
awards so you've got like a
a a sim shout in f the oscars in simlish
so you know
a lot of potential there at that very
well could be what it is
yeah you never know i'm very excited
because i mean
sims has been such a huge part of my
gaming life it was pretty much my
gateway
drug game to gaming yeah me too
and so i have a lot of issues with the
sims 4.
like sims 2 for me is still the best one
um
but i'm very excited to see a new
game pack because like the stuff packs
recently have not been
i mean eco lifestyle and nifty knitting
not the most exciting stuff
that that one thing that the team is
working on
is improving uh diversity and inclusion
in the
character creator so like black
hairstyles better skin tones
so uh i i feel like maybe i that was
kind of a newer development so that's a
little bit too soon for this but um i'm
excited to see
i feel like there's a lot more potential
a lot more they could do with the sims
4.
all right we don't have very long left
maybe 30 seconds or so before we go
over to the gamescom opening night live
pre-show um
quickly guys what are you looking out
for um in this one quickly wild card
predictions go launch titles i need more
launch titles
to know about them tap elven ring please
someone anyone please give it to me
anyone anywhere i'll take it
all right guys thank you so much for
joining me thank you everyone home for
joining us too
uh make sure to stay tuned to
youtube.com gamespot and gamespot.com
for all the big
announcements from gamescom 2020.
it's gamescom it's gamescom
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
great
[Music]
right
[Music]
bye
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
no
no
hello and welcome to the gamescom
opening night live 2020 pre-show
i'm kyle bossman and this is my hot and
stinky apartment
i realize you probably have a lot of
questions right now like who is this guy
not that important is this the show
no just to be clear this is the pre-show
this is you and me for the next 20
minutes getting excited about opening
night live proper
the big show that one is gonna look nice
that one's got jeff keely that one's got
a budget it's going to be fancy looking
not like this and then you might be
thinking wait
is the next 20 minutes just this guy
with his headband
talking to me about stuff no it's going
to be some of that
but most of the show is trailers we have
world premiere trailers right here for
the pre-show
if anything my job is just to smile at
you and fill time in between trailers
in fact we should i think start off with
a trailer we'll talk about opening night
live
it's going to be big and fun and awesome
but i feel like the best way to kick off
a pre-show is just to get
right into one our first world premiere
trailer
uh is a game that was just announced
earlier this year at an inside xbox
event
from bandai namco this is scarlet nexus
you have to be prepared for anything
intruders were just detected
we have to work together
we have so many different powers let's
do
you this your ways of doing things and i
have mine
so
hey
if you're just now joining us this is
the gamescom opening night live 2020
pre-show
that was a trailer for a video game and
not an anime and i'm kyle bossman not
important
for the next 20 minutes less than much
less than now we are counting down the
minutes
until the big show opening night live in
which you're going to get fresh looks
at fall guys season 2 destiny 2.
call of duty black ops cold war was just
announced yesterday we're already
getting to see more of that tonight
lots of things to see sydney goodman
from ign is going to be giving out the
gamescom awards for best pc game
best playstation game best xbox game as
well as
talking about some brand new shows from
ign that they are debuting this week at
gamescom
lots of stuff in onl it is it going to
be a chunky thick show
but in the meantime for this pre-show it
is time now
for another world premiere on our end
the game next that we're going to see
is called quantum error and parents let
me warn you now
it's time to put the kids to bed because
it's about to get
scary as hell in here i don't care if
you're in the western hemisphere and it
is the afternoon
put the kids to bed
[Music]
finally we did it
that artifact you recovered
well the answer to all our questions
we can control them now
use them to travel the stars
humanity's reach will be
infinite
we've got a lot more world exclusive
trailers to go more pre-show to go and
interview with jeff keely next
up we have a car brand
synonymous with racing and innovation
and a key partner of gamescom for years
ford they're about to exclusively reveal
the first ever car made with gamers for
gamers check it out
ford knows racing in 2019 we brought our
love of racing to gaming
and team godzilla was born and that was
just the beginning
in may we launched project p1 to design
a car
in collaboration with gamers for gaming
this project
was a global first and our designers let
their imagination go wild
so on to our first global announcement
please welcome
our first ever team godzilla project p1
model
god
[Music]
and now our second global announcement
you got us so excited
with project p1 that we are now
committing
to make a real-world version of this
groundbreaking car
if i didn't have games i think i
guess i would just be writing a lot more
video games and writing are absolutely
my two favorite passions and i just
managed to combine them into a job so i
feel like honestly i probably would have
finished a couple of books
if there was no game what else would i
do i mean i'm a i like tech but
you need to do things on the technology
and so if i can't play things
if i wasn't in the gaming yeah it'll be
a lot
of tv watching if there's out there a
universe where i'm not a gamer then i
probably would start to game i think i
will try something to put some smile on
the face of
everyone i would
watch a lot more movies and read more
books
and get bored
welcome back to the opening night live
pre-show uh
this is only the second year of o l
existing
uh but i think it is safe to say that
this year's will be
unconventional so to tell us what to
expect from
the show this year please welcome jeff
keely
we are now joined by uh jeff keeley
host and executive producer of opening
night live
hi doing jeff i'm doing great kyle how
are you
i'm doing okay uh so
back in april gamescom said we're going
digital this year
when did you start thinking about onl
and how that's going to look
well we knew last year we were going to
do another onl this year because it was
a big success but yeah we had no idea
what format was going to take normally
we were in cologne
this year we're doing it from los
angeles but
actually gamescom came to me and said we
definitely want to
do onl it's a digital event for the
whole world so even if we don't have
something physically in germany we still
want to do this show with you
and i said i was doing summer game fest
and maybe we can bring all these things
together to create
this grand finale uh for the show and
and all summer i was really hoping to
to do a show that was a little bit
bigger than i've been you know
broadcasting
from home here for many months and i
want to do something with kind of a set
and a little bit of spectacle to it and
bring the whole industry together and
that's that's what we're going to do
so is it going to be just as long as a
regular show
yeah we have like two hours of stuff to
show folks
um from across the industry you know
like the big stuff
uh the biggest games out there like call
of duty and then a lot of really
you know interesting titles of course
we're gonna have uh some amazing
next-gen stuff in the show
and uh and fall guys season two which uh
has you know become a thing over the
past couple of weeks so it's
it's really fun to have like the big and
the small and the the the surprises and
next gen all blended together but yeah
it's a full-blown show two hours
is it gonna be just back-to-back
trailers are you gonna do some
interviews and
demos you will definitely see trailers
you will
see some extended gameplay demos
of some titles as well there will be a
few interviews with a couple developers
uh we've got some special guests and one
thing i will say
kind of right out of the gate is that
this is not sort of
wall-to-wall shock and awe announcements
of new games similar to last year at
gamescom we have some really big updates
on
games that fans are excited about and
meaningful but you know the kind of big
surprise announcements
uh we have a few things in the show and
and you know we have lots of great
things planned for the game awards but
similar to last year this is really a
showcase of like big holiday games games
coming next year
that you know about so you know i i
would tell people to set their
expectations to be
really meaningful updates on existing
games versus
blowing you away with uh you know
surprise shock announcements
great jeff i'm personally looking
forward to the show
well the me too it's it's been really
fun to build this
but you know even working with our team
it's been challenging um to do things
safely
in the the era of of covid and it's been
it's been meant a lot to me that
gamescom has said we still want to do
this show and i think for all of us in
the industry
we want that big uh showcase so i'm just
really excited to honestly like
leave home do like a a have a set and
you'll see we've got like screens and
lights and it's it's
if we do it right we're going to
hopefully create that magic moment that
we haven't felt this summer right and a
lot of the events this summer have been
pre-taped and they've been they've been
great and and lots of cool game info but
i really wanted to do something
live with a lot of energy to it so if we
do things right that's what people are
about to see
very cool good luck with everything
thanks kyle thanks for hosting the
pre-show
i'm doing my best
so just so we're all on the same page
about what just happened that was
basically an interview with my boss
using questions that i mostly already
know the answers to so
considering all that i think that went
pretty well next up we do have another
world premiere trailer baby
vroom vroom hong kong for dirt 5.
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
let me show you what it's all about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
so you think like a vampire bit a car
and sucked out gas to be continued
it is now time for the part of the
pre-show
that i've been i've been reading your
live comments i see them right now
everybody's blowing up demanding kyle's
10 reasons to be excited for opening
night live well let's kick it off reason
number 10 to be excited for opening
night live 2020
feeling excited for next gen again
number nine jeff keeley wardrobe reveal
number eight reason to be excited for
opening night live 2020 destiny trailer
is usually pretty good
number seven it will mean this pre-show
is finally over
number six call of duty black ops cold
war number five reason to be excited for
o
l 2020 shadow drops
number four fall guys season two number
three reason to be excited for onl 2020
actual gameplay from a mysterious
playstation 5 exclusive
number two everything else in my life
sucks right now and
the number one reason to be excited for
opening night live
2020 jeff keeley said it's gonna be good
we have one final world premiere trailer
to show off and this trailer is an
announcement
of a switcher version of a popular game
from 2018 that can only be described as
dinosaursy enjoy
i think that things are going to turn
out differently huh
[Music]
well the ones before you did too
because they believed that they were in
control
and control well
here's the thing humanity is desperate
for it
we are seduced by it but we never really
possess it
you see life can be tenacious
and stubborn life will not be contained
and what makes us such unique creatures
is knowing the power of what we're up
against
and still believing that we can win
that's it that's all we have for you in
this very pre-show
please be excited for the actual opening
night live in which you'll see some
destiny 2. you'll see fall guys season 2
you'll see black ops cold war that
mysterious playstation 5 demo
some things we've probably never heard
of before i think it's going to be a
very good show i'm personally excited
about it
me i should thank you actually for
putting up with my nonsense for the last
20 minutes it is appreciated
but seriously enjoy the show
so what's the plan time to take control
our
world when we feel out of place
disconnected and divided there are
always repercussions
do we have what it takes all right i'm
going in
to be heroes what we're doing here could
change things forever
tonight we bring the world together
you're with us now
we celebrate who we are
what we are i'm with you every step of
the way
the future of gaming welcome to gamescom
opening night live
hello everyone i'm jeff keely and
welcome to gamescom opening night live
2020. now this year gamescom is of
course
a little different than normal and i
hope all of you and your families
are safe and healthy at home in 2020
games have comforted and connected us
more than ever and with the launch of
playstation 5 and xbox series x later
this year
games are only going to get better well
all summer i was hopeful we could get to
this very moment a
big live showcase filled with more than
35 games to kick off gamescom
2020. tonight you'll get a first look at
fall
guys season 2 and an extended gameplay
demo of ratchet and clank rift apart
for playstation 5. plus we might have a
couple surprises along the way too
but before we start i want to
acknowledge and thank all the game
developers
marketers and publishers who have worked
under challenging circumstances
to keep us entertained this show is
nothing without them or my production
team
and doing a show at this scale safely is
not easy
especially when all of you at home have
some pretty insane expectations
i hope tonight reminds you why you love
to play games
and with that we're going to move on to
our first game with a game that was just
announced yesterday call of duty black
ops cold war
and joining me is dan von drak from
raven to tell us about the game
and give you an exclusive sneak peek dan
how you doing
good jeff thanks for having me here this
is uh been a dream project for us to
work on from the from nearly the
beginning of development
we knew black ops cold war was going to
be a direct sequel to black ops 1
and we loved the idea of returning to
the pillars
built the black ops franchise deniable
operations conspiracy ground and history
and that shadowy world of paranoia and
we get to mix
all those together drop the player into
the 1980s at the height of the cold war
and it's really something that we know
would feel relevant to today and also
uniquely black ops
well you start playing with black ops
everyone wants to know
characters we saw yesterday in the
reveal trailers you know some familiar
faces so
you know woods mason like break it down
um how does this fit into the black op
cans you said it's a direct sequel so
are we going to see a lot of familiar
faces
yeah part of the fun of making this game
was bringing back the iconic characters
like woods and hudson and mason
and seeing how all those personalities
mix with some of the new characters
so the campaign takes place in 1981 and
we love that we've been able to have so
many connections to the original black
ops and really be that direct sequel to
the game
now one thing that i'm really excited
about this is you're pushing the
storytelling in kind of a new direction
with some branches and some
options about how you play through the
campaign can you maybe walk us through
your thinking there
yeah one of the driving forces from
early in development was to say let's
take this black ops through a ride
and infuse it with some player choice
and some player freedom anything we can
do to give the player a little more
ownership over their experience
so that starts with allowing the player
to create their own character for the
cold war campaign
they can name them and pick a military
background and really pretend they are
that black ops soldier that they want to
be
from there we wanted to take some of our
missions and infuse
optional objectives multiple paths and
some player choice moments
inside some of those missions and it was
fun to find that balance between the
hard driving call of duty action
and these more non-linear experiences
and some inside some of the missions
so with choice comes the player wanting
to feel that
impact so some of those choices earlier
in the game and some towards the end
will actually
shape the ending of the narrative of the
campaign all right so multiple endings
to this game
yeah absolutely absolutely that's that
was one of the big things for us it's
like we love that black ops has always
been willing to take
risks and we all know they did some of
this in black ops 2 and
with our story and with these features
we love playing homage to those early
black ops games
oh yeah i remember the numbers all right
uh well dan
we are excited to see more of it i know
multiplayer reveal is coming in
september but uh
since you got a switch there maybe you
could flip the switch on something
exclusive for us
what are you gonna show us
yeah absolutely this is really exciting
because this will be the first time
this outside the walls of the
development studio
this is the scene from early in the game
and it's a critical point that
really shows the narrative of the world
shows this threat that our heroes are
going to be battling
so let's take a look
1943 detailed information from the
manhattan project was stolen from los
alamos by the russian spy known as
perseus
1968 the vietnam war
vietcong soldiers orchestrated by
perseus
attempted to steal an american-made
nuclear bomb from a u.s
firebase five days ago
while on a mission we acquired intel
that perseus is in play again
and planning an attack on the west
purses the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world
mr hudson we're all aware of perseus
we're also aware he's more myth than
fact i mean
personally i think he's nothing more
than the russian boogeyman
general hague allow me to introduce the
man
as soon as the responder c.i.a
clandestine special officer russell
adler
he's one of the few people who even come
close to capturing
uh mr adler why should we take this
perseus threat seriously you don't have
to sir
yeah then a lot of innocent people are
gonna die and why do you say that
sir every time perseus has come into
play it shifted the balance of the cold
war
after 13 years of silence if he's active
something big is gonna happen something
that will affect the free world
mr president sir mr president mr
president this is jason hudson and
russell
i know their names who do you think
approved their
last mission
is the threat real yes sir we believe it
is
can you stop perseus we can sir i've
already submitted the requisition for my
team
sir their requests are highly irregular
most likely illegal if the press gets
old what the hell are you talking about
you know who we are every mission we go
on is illegal
sergeant woods plausible deniability is
the backbone of our work
now we're talking about preventing an
attack on the free men and women of the
world
give mr adler whatever he wants
gentlemen
you've been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
there is no higher duty there is no
higher honor
and while few people will know of your
struggles
rest assured the entire free world
will benefit i know you won't fail us
tonight we have some new game
announcements for you guys as well
including this one
a new next-gen narrative action
adventure game from reflector
entertainment in montreal
it's called unknown nine the game tells
the story of haruna a woman raised on
the streets of india
and haunted by visions of her own death
haruna struggles to understand her
mysterious innate abilities
to manipulate the unseen check out this
first look
i found you
i hear them
[Music]
is
[Music]
i hear them calling
[Music]
from
all right let's get to the gameplay one
of this year's biggest games has been
doom eternal tonight we've got an
exclusive first look
at the campaign expansion called the
ancient gods
part one check this out
foreign
please proceed with control assertive
aggression
again
2020 marks the 25th anniversary of a
legendary game studio
bioware tonight casey hudson and the
team wanted to give everyone
around the world a little taste of
what's next
casey over to you hey jeff it's great to
see you again
you know six years ago we were on the
stage with you at the 2014 game awards
accepting the game of the year for
dragon age inquisition
and since then we've been imagining new
ways to use next generation technology
to bring the world and characters of
dragon age to life
we're still in early production but we
thought it was time to give you the very
first look at how bioware's passionate
team of developers
are crafting this very special game
i've been a borrower for a really long
time so i've got to see it grow up and
turn from
from a company of 35 people to a company
of more than 300 people
there's amazing people in the industry
there's amazing stories to be told with
other people
i love that character so much
we're very experimental here at bioware
so we're always coming up with new stuff
we're always trying to improve
innovate and bring new characters to
life for our players and fans to enjoy
the world of dragon age really has got
it all
it's got frontier stories it's got
mystery
it's got hard-boiled detective stories
and of course it's all wrapped up in
kind of a fantasy setting
you really feel like you're the hero in
the dragon age world and
you're saving people dragon age to me
is a wonderful world to play in
i am really excited about the future of
dragon age
this is an original world original flora
original wildlife original architecture
that makes it fun to explore and
discover
in the next dragon age we get an
opportunity to to see new things new
places
and interact with people who lived and
grew up in these spaces as well
for the game we're working on now we
want to tell a story what happens when
you don't have power
what happens when the people in charge
aren't willing to address the issues
the things that you can expect in the
next installment are going to be stories
that focus on the people around you
and the friends and family you make
something we'll be able to look forward
to in dragon age
is a really close relationship with game
characters who really become real for
you
we want characters to either be loved or
hated one of the best examples of that
is soulless
half the community wants to kill them
half the people want to marry him then
another part want to do both
they call me the dread wolf
what will they call you when this is
over
bioware and ea has been one of the
forerunners in using
motion magic technology and that makes
it way more realistic
when you're looking at the characters
and the way they walk and move and
interact in the world players wanting
that suspension of disbelief that this
wonderful collection of digital pixels
is actually a living breathing soul
no no no it's okay that's the good kind
of rumble
i actually designed bosses i help with
the creature design team as well so i do
all like the big threats that you have
to go up against
nobody dies on my watch for the wardens
choice is a big part of what dragon age
is as a franchise
the decisions you make can affect change
in the world decision
making can mean that a party member
lives or a party member
dies and it means owning your outcome
and reactivity to
the choices that you do make i just love
the possibilities that dragon age offers
us
and i'm excited to explore a lot more of
them
to me that potential is what gets you up
in the morning
it's a fantastic opportunity
every time
next up it's time for something special
great scott i think there's a serious
miscalculation
wow wait you're uh what what's his name
back to the future i'm emil brown
doctor of physics not on medicine and
certainly not that quack from rick and
morty
yeah we know who you are but what are
you doing here i did come back from the
future to this
precise moment on august 27 2020
because it's imperative we launched
certain simulator two right now
and what exactly do you have to do with
surgeon simulator
during the mid 20th century some friends
of mine from a large shire university
invented a state-of-the-art medical
training facility otherwise known
as the surgeon simulator training
program
now 70 years later we've digitized the
experience
it's unbelievable you can access the
program
through your computer and then be
medically trained
from the comfort of your keyboard and
it's available as a
great scope this very moment
tonight i want a world premiere a few
examples
of some of the incredibly successful
test subjects who have already completed
the course
so you're saying a world premiere will
save our future only time will tell
and speaking of time i'm off to another
world premiere
avengers 26 the return of the son of
thanos
opening 2077. and with that
i leave you the fade of the human race
in your hands
just make sure you play search
principles
too doctor's orders
where does this path go
he looks good now grab the good arm and
bring it in here
we're dying he's dying
my fingers
jesus christ
doc brown introducing jacksepticeye
playing surgeon simulator only
opening night live all right well if you
thought that crossover was kind of crazy
wait until you get a load of this next
game announcement that
i don't think anyone probably saw coming
check this out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tonight is just the start of gamescom
2020. over the next three days there are
more streams from ign and web media
with in-depth looks at games a digital
cosplay contest and some special new
shows
just for gamescom your portal for all
things gamescom this year is gamescom
now which you can check out
at gamescom.global now one game you'll
hear more about later on ign's post show
is this one a return of two classic
characters
that i love check this out
[Music]
in a world gone strange
one elite force stands against the
darkness
but even they could use some help here
slip on this little beauty for a fact
sam i blind oh hello yes
[Music]
[Music]
the return of sam and max yes all right
and now it's time to say hello to my
wonderful co-host for o
l from ign please say hello to sydney
goodman
thank you jeff what's up everyone i'm
sydney goodman and i am
thrilled to be here gamescom is always
such a fun event and throughout the show
tonight i'll be telling you about all
the different ways that ign is involved
in this year's festivities
but first i have an award to announce
the winner of
best nintendo switch game is little
nightmares 2
huge congratulations like i said ign is
going to be here for all of gamescom
with great shows such as
gamescom studio where you can find me
and my co-hosts for all day long
games content interviews dev talks and
more plus we have gamescom awesome
indies
the show with and for indie developers
that premieres
saturday august 29th at 7pm the central
european time so be sure to tune in for
more announcements and special guests
and now let's go back to jeff for our
next big world premiere
awesome thank you so much sid we are so
excited to see what's in the
the game com studio and also awesome
indies and i'm going to be on the daily
show
tomorrow so looking forward to that all
right well on to our next game
in the next world of warcraft expansion
players will journey beyond the mortal
world of azeroth to a place where no
living soul has set foot before
the shadow lands the afterlife of an
entire warcraft universe
the infinite realms of the shadow lands
are watched over by different factions
known as covenants
each holding dominion over a different
aspect of the afterlife
and depending on how someone lived their
mortal life they may end up as part of
one of these covenants when they cross
over into the shadow lands
today we're excited to give you a closer
look at the noble and pure
kirian covenant from the realm of
bastion who are charged with carrying
the souls of the dead into the beyond
so sit back and get ready for the world
premiere of bastion
the first in blizzard entertainment's
new four-part series of animated shorts
called afterlives enjoy
[Laughter]
light save my soul
[Music]
uther where
where am i welcome
to bastian
[Music]
you led a truly selfless life
and for that you have been chosen
chosen to shed your mortal burdens
and join the ranks of the ascended
serving to ferry the souls of the dead
unto the shadowlands i serve
the light and my work is not
done there is an evil that must be
there is no evil here the darkness was
sealed within the maw
long ago you're wrong he destroyed
my home murdered my people and my
king he must be punished you are an
aspirant now you must accept your new
purpose
and purge yourself of this desire for
vengeance
what i desire is
justice
davos why are you training this soul
it is beneath your station as a paragon
he cannot let go
he continues to demand retribution for
his death
and this concerns you many souls take
eons to ascend
yes but this one seems
broken thanios unlike any soul i have
seen
i have begun to wonder whether he was
deemed worthy of bastion
by mistake be careful
i would not let the archon hear such a
thought
in time he will forget
trust our ways trust
the path
devos how long must we train
until you are ready to ascend
and what is keeping me from ascension
nothing but the memory of your mortal
life
how can i forget when i can still
feel his blade
your soul is wounded
who did this to you he was
my student he betrayed us
[Music]
all
the runes on his blade were unmistakable
this dark agent runs free on a mortal
world
with the power of the maw itself in hand
our realm is imperiled impossible
the more is inescapable you must return
to the path if he had purged his life
we never would have known of this
calamity
the path is flawed enough
the order of the shadow shadowlands
depends on the execution of our
eternal charge you
will abandon this course
as you command my archon
uther the time of your ascension
has come i thought i was not ready
do you wish to see him punished
i do then prepare yourself
[Music]
the moment he falls
we will claim him
i see
[Music]
only darkness
before me
[Music]
now cast him into the maw
return him to the darkness he served
his eternal suffering
awaits
he was my student
remember what he did
and take your vengeance
not vengeance
[Music]
justice
all right hope you guys enjoyed that
exclusive look at bastian now we know
many of you can't wait to experience
shadow lands and our friends at blizzard
want you to know
the wait is almost over
[Music]
[Music]
october 27th it is official
we have so much more opening night live
still to go for you ratchet and clank
playstation
5. uh much more stay tuned all right but
now it's time for the announcement of a
new universe that is coming to gaming
for the first time
with a project from a canadian studio
check this out
they have returned
they corrupted divided
conquered until
finally the gates of the celestial realm
were thrown open
our last remaining hope the stormcast
eternals vengeance made
manifest
unbound unbroken
we will take back what the dead have
ravaged
now you guys may remember back in june i
had some masked
fun with my buddy crash bandicoot
announcing crash 4 it's about time
with the game coming in october crash of
course had to come back for opening
night live so let's bring him out
everybody crash bandicoot
what he's where
[Music]
[Music]
poor crash apparently didn't get the
memo about gamescom but to tell us more
about what we just saw i'm joined by lou
studdard from toys for bob
uh lou what did we see there with uh
crash in the games combat
uh apparently you saw him wandering
around cologne but uh what he was
hinting at
was kind of our reveal of what we call
flashback tapes which are a brand new
style of level that we are announcing
here today
okay so how do these flashback levels
kind of play into the overall crash for
narrative yeah so the way that the the
flashback tape levels work is that
they are kind of a peek back in time to
the 90s
when neocortex was actually testing on
crash and coco
before the events of crash bandicoot 1.
and they're kind of these
devious puzzle rooms that we've made
and they're really hard and they're
really awesome and they're
super creative and we can't wait to get
people's hands on them
yeah no i i got to play a demo of this a
few weeks ago and that was a challenge
so i can't imagine
um how nefarious these are um how are
they going to be sort of integrated into
the game are they
they optional like offshoot stuff or how
do you how do you get to them
sure so players actually have to collect
the flashback tapes
in the levels themselves uh they're an
object that they can pick up
and to actually pick them up they have
to reach them in the level without dying
it's kind of our homage to the death
routes from the original trilogy so
players have to
reach these objects in the level pick
them up and then once they get them
they'll get access
to these unique levels so beyond the
pure
challenge uh what other funds how are
these fun for players
to kind of experience what do they get
to do on them
sure so one of the things that we did
was we actually used these as
like i said puzzle rooms really kind of
fun nefarious devious ways for
crash to really express that pure
platforming
kind of uh aspect of gameplay that we
know and love about the franchise but
then
narratively for us it was really cool to
layer in
kind of a unique perspective to the
franchise this is the moment when
cortex is really excited about the
prospect of
crash being on his team because crash
was originally
created by cortex and so this is a weird
point in time that's never really been
explored in the games before
awesome all right well crash 4 it's
about time looks
phenomenal lou we cannot wait to check
it out
in october thanks for joining us yeah
thanks for having me
awesome all right well we will be right
back after this for more
gamescom opening night live
i have become terror
the unseen predator
alone the hordes of enoch will fall
before me
but together this entire planet
will fear us
the anomaly alters us each in our own
ways
yet we are drawn down the same road
into the dark heart of
[Music]
we will creation the source whatever it
holds
whatever it takes
so
welcome to the hyperscape enter
a contender yes
time to find it
welcome to necromunda i can see you're
new here
let me get you up to speed the
underhives named well
a sprawl of humanity suffering away like
ants
deep underground where we ain't causing
trouble but are rich boys and girls
no matter how loud we are and do we ever
make some noise
every all lock says they could shoot the
tail off a lash work
and they'd splash your head from 20
paces for saying they couldn't
i don't want to say immortal but when
their armor
blood skin and will are of iron it's a
potent combo
why would someone like you want to know
about an all-female gang of psychopaths
drug dealers killers cloners and
oh makes sense and esha
will cut you up just for the fun of
goliaths are big that's it
anything smaller than them doesn't
deserve to live
and they're just as happy filling you
with lead as they are smashing you to
pieces with a powerball
now mixing that whole pot together in a
place like this
you can imagine what happens chaos
gang warfare for wealth for power
hell sometimes just for fun so think
you're ready
necromanda under high fours comes to
playstation 4
xbox one and pc on september 8th
[Music]
i envision the future gaming to be quite
bright
and quite online the next generation of
consoles will clearly allow
aaa and indie developers to build more
creative driven
games that i hope will cover more diver
subjects
i want to play all kinds of stories
about people and places both real
and imagined i want comedy games i want
autobiographical games i
really want to see what people can do
with the media profuse games
us
[Music]
you know one of the things i love about
opening night is that we can show you
the biggest games in the industry and
also
smaller titles that should be on your
radar so pay attention to this next game
it comes from a team of two
in sweden tuxedo labs over the past
three years developer dennis gustafson
has built his own game engine to realize
his
vision for a fully destructible game
world what he's building has
absolutely blown me away so i asked
dennis to prepare a special trailer just
for tonight
i hope you're equally inspired by the
ideas in this next game
definitely one to watch tear down
[Music]
so
[Music]
last year at opening night live we
announced little nightmares to to the
world
well the team at tarsier studios hasn't
shown anything
since but that changes right now here is
a first look at the gameplay
of little nightmares 2 which is coming
next february
with more to come throughout the week at
gamescom including a live demo
on gamescom studio tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
nice all right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
crap
[Music]
i'm wwe hall of famer jerry the king
lawler and i'm reuniting with my old
buddy mauro ronaldo to bring you all the
over-the-top action in wwe 2k
battleground mamma mia
this is great this arcade style video
game is
over the top outrageous with over 70 wwe
superstars and legends
crawling it out like never before
oh no hold on to your 2k morrow look out
below
wwe is l-i-t
you know i'm a little more old school
than morrow so i can't wait to see these
wwe legends
teach these kids a thing or two and you
know what here's a closer look at the
insane action
it's a great evening for wwe
action oh wow
take that morrow man it's so good to see
the fella twins at their best
now let's keep this party rolling with
another matchup
look out moro the undertaker has risen
and finn balor is about to be taken for
his last ride
mia what a move finish him oh no
he just hit the snooze button how do you
lose like that what's the matter with
you legends
this is just an example of the
pandemonium that you're gonna experience
when you head to the battlegrounds
that's a big toy hammer
oh i can't believe my eyes seth rollins
delivers the stop
what a night what a night this is the
greatest thing i've ever seen
pre-order wwe 2k battlegrounds today
and brawl without limits
mamma mia oh sorry moro i know that's
your line
hello again i have even more awards to
announce so let's get
right down to it the winner of best
action adventure game
is watchdogs legion the city needs a
resistance
and it starts with you what do you say
i'm the perfect shot the winner of the
best action game
is star wars squadrons
the winner of best multiplayer game is
operation
tango
i used to be an explorer the winner of
best indie game is curious expedition 2.
did not believe what i had witnessed
it was time for the world to learn
my name congratulations to
all the winners as i mentioned ign will
be here for all of gamescom with great
shows and new ways for you to get all
your gaming news
check it out gamescom 2020 is the heart
of gaming and you can keep to the beat
right here on ign
we've turned the single biggest show and
gaming into five gamescom now is your
virtual show floor with up to the second
live coverage gamescom daily show
gamescom's first ever
late night talk show our gamescom
awesome indie show the freshest deep
cuts in indie gaming
and finally the gamescom best of show
including
the gamescom award gamescom 2020 is
available on ign and wherever you stream
gamescom now
and now it is time to talk about that
best action game winner
star wars squadrons this is a new
immersive space combat game from motive
studios that delivers the ultimate star
wars pilot fantasy
we've missed those in squadrons you'll
suit up and fly for both the new
republic and the galactic empire
across intense 5v5 multiplayer battles
as well as an all new authentic
single-player story set after the events
of star wars episode vi
return of the jedi today we'll get a
glimpse of what squadron's story has to
offer
by taking a brief look at one of the
single-player missions featuring some
light narration
by the motive team let's check it out
we all choose our path light or dark
freedom or destruction the empire chose
to destroy alderaan in order to spread
fear
and douse the fires of rebellion but the
heroic pilots of the rebel alliance have
chosen to keep
fighting to show the empire that we are
not
afraid it was their bravery that ended
palpatine's reign
and brought about our new republic
however
the empire lives on shattered though it
may be
as i speak imperial forces are edging
toward the bournemia sector hoping to
end our new republic before we find our
footing
as their empire collapses they try to
tighten their grip
but the galaxy is changing and you can
be a part of it
with the help of brave and daring pilots
this war can
end make a choice fly with the new
republic
change our galaxy for the better
hi i'm suzanne hunker narrative producer
on star wars squadrons
our single-player story is one of daring
pilots and deep-seated rivalries
take titan squadron hunt down this
starhawk
and eliminate it gladly add more sloan
over the course of the story you'll fly
as two pilots on
opposite sides of the war and like all
modes in star wars squadrons
you'll have the option to experience
every mission fully immersed in vr
right antilles rogue squadron i hear
you're the reason i was able to finally
get a com through
today we're giving you a glimpse of an
early imperial mission
behind enemy lines one of our spies
agent thorne has discovered vital
intelligence on project starhawk
your mission is to extract her from an
orbital outpost above hosni and prime
behind enemy lies you'll have to
eliminate perimeter defenses
the outpost is defenseless when you've
secured the area
you will escort the gladius to the
outpost and our extraction team will
acquire
agent thorne once thorn is secure
reach your gozanti cruisers and return
to the overseer
cover our escape and escort us to the
jump point we have republic corvettes
inbound
each mission will immerse you into the
escalating conflict between the new
republic
and a shattered empire debrief with your
squad mates between missions
customize and master all eight
starfighters and join the galaxy's
finest
i need you focused and ready to
[Music]
from go runs at the nadiri dockyards
to setting a trap in the xavian abyss
the story of these rival squadrons will
push the war to the brink
and define the galaxy for years to come
i look forward to seeing you in combat
october 2nd
that is not all ea has to share from a
galaxy far
far away today at star wars galaxy edge
you can enter the world of batu
where you can visit oga's cantina or
jump into the millennium falcon on a run
to smugglers cove it was this incredible
adventure at disneyland resort and walt
disney world resort that inspired
the sims latest game pack check this out
[Music]
um
uh
yep
[Music]
yes
[Music]
there is even more star wars to come
later in the show
lego star wars the skywalker saga is up
and as we move into our second hour
we've got fall guys season two still to
come the reveal of that which i can't
wait for you guys to see
and of course a gameplay demo of ratchet
and clank
rift apart for playstation 5. but right
now
you might remember this next game from
annapurna interactive from last year's
microsoft e3 event
and today i'm excited to share a new
announcement from the team
this interactive thriller about a man
stuck in a time loop
is one of this year's most intriguing
indie titles and now
they've added an absolutely all-star
cast to the game
here's a whole new look at 12 minutes
all right close your eyes i want you to
think of a flower
look at its contours its curves
now i want you to imagine it changing
moving backward returning to its blood
think of that bud an open
look at it as a whole then silently
repeat these phrases
may you be free from suffering may you
be
free from fear may you know
peace and joy
[Music]
that's going to be a really special
indie game so glad to announce that here
on the show
now last year at the game awards we
announced godfall a new
looter shooter coming to playstation 5
and pc from counter play
tonight we've got a quick sneak peek of
one of the new valor plates with more
footage coming
as part of gamescom 2020 check this out
so
we have much more o l to come exclusive
looks at lego star wars the skywalker
saga
fall guys season two
wait until you see what the media tonic
guys are up to and so much more but
first
i'm sure you saw that earlier this week
heart of deimos warframe's newest
uh expansion was released on pc xbox and
ps4
and today it's also on switch all
platforms
here's a look at the heart of damos
expand explore
tear the veil asunder subvert new
territory
to our sovereign ways
but that was what it wanted to
it raged unchecked through
metal bones
flash
life we are
infested with it
what visitors now
the gateway is failing the jars
close the final
heartbeat approaches
have you tried turning it off and on
again
but before we follow
we shall scream
there is one who will hear
the heart of damos
[Music]
so many people have been discovering or
rediscovering video games during
lockdown whether it be
older people or bored teenagers or
middle-aged parents who suddenly find
they have to do something together with
their kids
and i think i've given out more advice
about video games in 2020 than any other
time
ever and as a result it's more important
than ever that we keep making
different interesting things for folks
you are
i hope everybody gets healthy and safely
through this corona
virus time care about other people
and wear your masks
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
conditions
[Music]
alive
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys we're back officially
into hour two we've got an
hour more of great stuff to show you
destiny two beyond light staces you're
gonna see a brand new look at that
fall guys season two and ratchet and
clank for playstation 5
and so much more across the next hour
opening night live continues and it just
is the start of gamescom 2020. but right
now on september 25th
mafia definitive edition launches a
comprehensive built from the ground up
remake of the original mafia tonight
we've got the exclusive debut
of the next trailer called a life of
reward too big to ignore
which deals with tommy's induction into
the salieri crime family
check this out
all these guys in this room
they're here because they have the only
thing that matters to me
the only thing that should matter to any
of us
you know what that is tommy they're
loyal
that's right
one day you're busting your back doing
an honest day's work in a city that's
been trying to scrape you off its heels
since the day you stepped off the boat
and the next your stuff in your pockets
full of salieri's dirty money
tommy teach these boys a lesson
break every bone in their bodies
you want me to become one of those wall
street boys don't sass me tommy
i'm trying to teach you the ropes so you
don't get strangled by them
now you stay straight with me you're
going to be living the high lifetime
you abuse my trust don salieri
you won't ever need to worry about me
okay then
welcome to the family
next we're going to introduce you to a
turn-based multiplayer strategy fps from
a team in montreal canada
lemnis gate is coming in early 2021 and
has a unique mechanic
built around a 25 second time loop
check this out
[Music]
foreign
next spring get ready to experience
memorable moments and non-stop
action from all nine star wars films in
lego star wars the skywalker saga
the entire series has been reimagined
with new
fun-filled lego humor and now we've got
your first look
at the gameplay trailer
i want to learn the ways of the force
and become a jedi like my father
the force is unusually strong with him
that much is clear
twisting by the dark side
young skywalker has become
[Music]
there is another
and from the resistance your sister leia
sent me
we need your help
[Music]
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Music]
not him
[Music]
i am a jedi like my father before me
so be it jedi
[Music]
man lego star wars looks so fun coming
to next gen as well
all right we'll be right back with more
world premieres from huge new games like
ratchet and clank
rift apart medal of honor above and
beyond and destiny 2. but before that
here's a look at a game that is
launching tonight on nintendo switch and
steam
it's called struggling from frontier a
fun physics-based platformer where up to
two players
control troy our fleshy hero check this
out and remember you can play this
tonight
[Music]
like
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
where are we we're near little hope
what's more proof is needed that the
devil walks among us in little hole
[Music]
[Music]
i gotta say the game that i've given the
most hours to that i love going back to
is assassin's creed odyssey
not to say since origins came out this
new reboot of the size is free uh so to
speak that was my first time getting
into it
and i have put almost 400 hours into
sasha's creed odyssey
at the moment i enjoy to play fall guys
with my friends it's very funny easy to
learn but hard to master
i have a few games that i binge play um
games that i return to every year
uh halo the entire master chief
collection is really a big one for me
where that's concerned
but i also still just casually binge
animal crossing and i've been doing that
basically all year
i haven't put down animal crossing since
i downloaded it i find
the daily repetitive rhythm so soothing
and predictable
although much like my house my island is
still a complete tip
up next we have the award for best
microsoft xbox game
and the winner is tell me why
congratulations to dontnod entertainment
well after a big day of gamescom events
and announcements you'll be happy to
know that ign is going to help you
digest
all that info with gamescom daily show
where you can get all the daily
highlights and a late night show
experience
from gamers for gamers back to you jeff
thank you very much sid uh and by the
way congratulations to
dontnod for uh tell me why a really
important game that is out now that you
can play
on xbox xbox and game pass and as we
know
there's a lot going on in the world and
that goes beyond the pandemic
between social conflicts we're seeing in
the news and acts of nature
we can see how vulnerable we as people
can sometimes be
and now i think it's as important time
as ever to remember
to come together and support one another
we are a global gaming community there
are millions of people watching tonight
and i know we're all here
because we love games and we know that
games are
good in the world and can bring us
together and i think we've all felt that
in 2020 so i think that's really
important to remember
amongst all the games and trailers all
right well one game
one one way as a community we can come
together to do some good is the gamescom
forest gamescom has launched a
reforestation project
by planting a gamescom forest together
with the community
gamers worldwide can go to
gamescom.global and donate to plant more
trees
so let's plant a forest together all
right well now we're going to move on to
another game
and this one was announced back in may
chorus is a dark space combat shooter
where players take control of nara on a
quest to destroy
the dark cult that created her featuring
rich ray traced 4k
60 fps environments on next-gen hardware
here is the first look at gameplay from
chorus
you have broken my heart
for your betrayal you
will be broken
[Music]
how many crowns have you won if one game
has defined the summer of 2020
it absolutely is fall guys from
mediatonic in london
and devolver this game is setting
records and putting a much needed smile
on everyone's face
fall guys i think represents our
industry at its absolute
best well soon the fall guys experience
will evolve with season two
there's a lot of new stuff coming and
tonight
mediatonic is about to give you an
exclusive sneak peek
at what's next get ready i think the
internet
is about to freak out here it is fall
guys
season two
hey i'm joe i'm the game designer on
full guys ultimate knockout and i just
want to reach out and say thank you to
everyone who's been playing and enjoying
the game so far
as a team we've been looking at all the
fan arts the memes and the montages that
people have been posting online and the
response to the game has really blown us
away
today we just wanted to give everyone
their first sneak peek at the rounds and
the costumes that they can be enjoying
as part of four guys season two
in season two you'll be dressing your
full guy as a medieval hero
and competing across brand new rounds
inspired by epic quests from the middle
ages
traverse giant drawbridges dodge
swinging axes and scale movable seed
ramps in the quest for ultimate
game show glory
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed the sneak peek of
poor guy season two we're still adding
the fishing touches to development but
if you want to stay up to date then at
poor guys game on twitter is where you
want to be
see you on the start line
my father has colorado in the palm of
his hand
and he's afraid to close his fist
i am not
is
liberty's got more brains and cunning
than both her brothers put together
she's the only one who could actually
run colorado she's already tried once
vic's a depraved child and vows a brain
without a spine
the years my father wasted grooming them
for glory
when i was right there
down
go back to arizona rangers then i'll
pretend none of this happened
stay and you die alone
[Music]
i really haven't found any new
appreciation for gaming at this time
because my appreciation for gaming
before
is
you get to travel all over the world in
games which is something i've always
taken for granted
at the moment i'm playing go sushima and
you know i kind of prefer to the real
japan just because i've heard that in
real life
they don't let you run around with time
honors i appreciate games
a lot more than films music or whatever
and it's just fine
for me to to have the time to play with
friends or
even with my family to have a lot of fun
i've been mostly at home with small
children and gaming is the only thing
that i get to do for myself
anymore i find it's not only an escape
it's also
a way to challenge my brain gaming is
becoming clearly more important for a
lot of people
you know play is a natural instinct and
from animal crossing to the last of us
part two or
ori yes yes it's definitely an
incredible time now
to be a gamer yes
hey everyone i'm vince sampela head of
respawn entertainment
when we set out to create medal of honor
above and beyond we knew we wanted to
bring the series back to its roots
the medal of honor franchise is known
for its powerful and exciting
single-player stories
that put the player in the boots of a
soldier who was there it's a series that
is grounded in history which tells
emotionally authentic stories
peter hirschman who directed the
original medal of honor in 1999
is back at the helm of this project
you'll hear more from him in just a bit
peter and i actually worked together on
medal of honor allied assault in 2002
and i'm really happy he's joined us at
respond to craft a completely new
experience in vr
the team is creating a riveting and
emotional journey through world war ii
like you've never seen or played
it weaves in the personal stories of the
veterans and survivors of the war
through powerful interviews that help
set the stage for what players will
experience
it's more than just a game we could not
be more excited to show the world
the next look at medal of honor above
and beyond and the game's action-packed
story
let's take a look
i know this is the first time some of
you will see combat
i know you're scared let me be clear
with all of you
i'm scared too
welcome to france gentlemen i lead the
local resistance cell
something big is happening inside
gestapo headquarters
and we don't know what it is we're gonna
have to improvise here
members of the resistance are perhaps
the bravest
people fighting in this war
but you really should stop there is no
future
in it sorry to interrupt
[Music]
lieutenant
it'll be a wild ride but we'll get you
there
jet fighters brace yourselves
like i said boom
there are things as people
i'm willing to sacrifice myself for
somehow this motley crew has been tasked
with saving civilization
god help us all
[Music]
thank you so much vince that looks
incredible and now we're here with
respawn entertainment's peter hirschman
game director on medal of honor above
and beyond to talk more about their new
vr experience uh peter i gotta say the
trailer
really grabbed me such an incredible
story that you're telling to
tell us a bit about this single player
experience what can we expect
well jeff thank you for having us on the
show the i'm representing a whole team
back at respawn that's been working
really hard on this and it's so exciting
to premiere the trailer
uh with you uh metal uh going back to
its roots
was always about putting uh the player
in the boots of a soldier
fighting in world war ii um and with vr
we're able to do that
in almost a literal way uh it's it's
definitely the most immersive experience
most immersive combat experience i've
ever been able to work on
um and the story follows uh you as a
player being recruited into
the office of strategic services um
commonly known as the oss
uh and their mission was sabotage
espionage
search and rescue everything uh in
between uh you name it they did it
and they're known by a different set of
initials now the the cia
but during world war ii uh they sent
operatives
all over europe deep behind enemy lines
uh and that allows us to tell a story
where you get to go to these places and
locations and
participate in events that really helped
shape
the outcome of the work one of the
things i love about the trailer is you
can tell there's a lot of
interactivity in the environment
emerging
the story it gamepl like it's all kind
of through a first person perspective
but there are some story sequences how
do you tell the story
oh well we shot we shot over 120 pages
or div
you know which is more than some feature
films we had a huge
international cast of phenomenal actors
uh it was fantastic
and the story follows a a classic three
three act structure
um act one is working with the french
resistance
getting ready for the invasion act two
is d-day itself and the fight uh to get
to berlin
uh and then the third act is dealing
with the nazi secret weapon program
which involved things like the 262 uh
jet and the v2 rocket and things that
could have really turned the tide of the
war
if if we hadn't stopped them um so you
get to go
on this this journey you know this story
um and the story is shot
all from your perspective because it's
vr
your head is the camera we don't have
cut scenes we don't have edits
everything uh everything revolves around
your perspective so you experience this
story
completely in first person as as if you
are there um so it creates a much more
intimate and
and uh emotional connection with the
characters and the things going on
around you
uh it it was an incredible way to to
shoot one of our animators stood in for
the
the player throughout uh throughout the
three weeks that we're on stage
um and all the actors are are always
reacting and talking to you directly and
in vr it's just
a powerful thing it's all about building
that emotional
connection and just makes the experience
more
authentic well you and vince i know this
this series is really close to your
heart and uh
i'm like wow there's there's so much
there to experience it looks really
rich and detailed obviously authentic as
well um you know paying tribute
um to everyone that was involved in in
the war
i i wanted to ask you also about
multiplayer which is something that
respawn is really
known for and you've had a great single
player experience but i hear
you might all be doing mp2 oh
well yeah i mean the thing about vr is
that
you know i've spent so much i mean we
know each other a long time
you know you know your career trying to
map natural human movements to uh to a
controller
and just figuring out like making feel
good and one of the hardest ones is
is leaning and in vr you know how you
duck you just duck and and how you lean
in vr
you just lean and so the ability to lean
around a corner just kind of peek around
the corner and see where the bad guy is
is just it heightens the tension so much
it makes it
it makes it feel all the more real and
when you put that into a multiplayer
experience
it just raises it to a whole nother
level so we are shipping
in addition to the campaign we are
shipping uh a full suite of vr modes
uh including a few that you can only do
in vr and we're really excited about
uh people playing those uh um you know
after it comes out wow well definitely a
full-blown vr experience i gotta say i'm
really excited
to put the headset on and try this and
it's coming out later this year right
coming out holiday so uh yeah fasten
your seat belts uh
we're we are so excited to to bring it
to players we've been working on a long
time like like you mentioned it's a
passion project for
for vince and i and everyone at respawn
um it's
it's uh it's a wonderful full circle uh
experience for a lot of us that got our
start our careers working on those
original set going back first one and
and and uh allied assault and now to be
able to bring above and beyond
uh to a whole new generation is uh is
one of the most exciting things we've
been involved with
awesome thank you so much peter opening
night live we'll be right back and in
the meantime here's a look at a new game
that is launching
tonight
the world was broken fractured
by the magic the vow keepers said they
would protect us from
spellstorms still rage across the ruins
of the hollow lands
this is proof they said
it isn't safe it can't be controlled
magic cannot be used
[Music]
but i am a battle mage
i have broken my vow
and now i fight to break free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so many great games in xbox game pass
and many of tonight's games are in it as
well
uh every year at gamescom we like to
highlight some incredible games made in
germany and tonight
we have a special announcement about one
of the most legendary german games of
all time created by
factor five enjoyed
factor five was so far ahead of the
curve and each of their games pushed
game technology as far as possible
i'd say they're one of the greatest
indie developers of all time
this was the first game that allowed me
to completely fulfill my musical vision
it defined my career and the fans have
been there ever since
to this day it's one of my proudest
works
[Music]
[Music]
in june bungie revealed a new era of
destiny 2 that starts on november 10th
with beyond light
for the first time ever guardians will
add a new elemental power to their
arsenal
the dark power of stasis with stasis
players will take on the powers of
darkness to control and dominate the
battle
here's an all-new look at stasis from
destiny 2
beyond light
floodgates are open the darkness is here
as you step away from the light
we need only look inward
focus your power let it grow
our fight is far from over
let them come this is their fate
one after another
[Music]
[Music]
i have one more award to give out
tonight and that is best sony
playstation game
so without further ado the winner
is cyberpunk 2077
congratulations of course there are
even more awards than the ones i
announced tonight so check out the
gamescom awards user voting where you
can vote for your favorite streamer
gamescom's most wanted and best of
gamescom the winners will be revealed at
gamescom best of show along with cool
cosplayers esports and more
so tune in on sunday august 30th at 8pm
central european time
to see the grand finale of this year's
gamescom where we give gamers the stage
that's it for me tonight but before i
turn it back to jeff i just want to say
that i hope everyone out there is
staying safe and healthy
we're all in this together so take care
back to you jeff
thank you very much uh sydney and it's
great to have you on the show
again this year uh all right well a lot
of people have been wondering
what will the next generation of gaming
feel like how will it be different
what is that generational difference
well
back in june we saw the announcement of
ratchet and clank rift apart from
insomniac games
a title which uses the power of
playstation 5
the ssd hard drive and the dual sense
controller to create an experience that
insomniac says
is only possible on brand new hardware
well
now it's time for you to decide if you
see the difference here's an extended
uninterrupted demo of live playstation 5
gameplay
of ratchet and clank rift apart enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hmm and not far from where we last saw
him
we may still have time to put a stop to
this
oh dear
let's show
bringing out the big guns
it feels good to be back in action
last one
the train's pulling away let's go
is
[Music]
soon everything you see will be
mine
say goodbye
[Music]
what did
was that supposed to happen hitting
nefarious device seems to have
destabilized reality
the bridge is shot there has to be
another way across
hmm the rips appeared to react to your
device
try pointing it at one of them
oh
this is worse than i had imagined
it's ratchet and clank
sand sharks from above
my heroes
i knew you'd come
or at least a very large octopus
i will never get used to that hey at
least we're on the same planet this time
nefarious is on the other side of that
building let's get moving before he does
anything else to break reality
yeah i kind of wish he was doing a worse
job
he must have more planned than he is
telling us
that's what i'm afraid of
wow
can't wait to see what's new
that's all of them we have to get the
dimensionator away from nefarious
the dimensions are weakening
[Music]
considerably
[Music]
well it is certainly not good
uh
[Applause]
ratchet we are too late
ratchet
[Music]
whoa
there you have it ratchet and clank rift
apart and now i am joined by marcus
smith and mike daly from insomniac games
uh
guys it was so great to see that uh long
uninterrupted demo of uh rift apart and
i have so many questions uh it's amazing
to see what you're doing with
the power of ps5 and the ssd um
let me ask you first marcus what are you
able to do with rift apart that you
haven't been able to do before in a
ratchet game because of the power of ps5
i mean first and foremost it's just pure
horsepower enables us to
fill our worlds with the kind of density
and life that we've never been able to
do before
more importantly perhaps though is the
dimensional shifting that we have going
on
which uses the ssd that allows us to
fling the player
from planet to planet to planet uh
lightning fast like in
way way faster than we've ever been able
to do before
yeah the the rift tether we saw that in
the uh demo we had seen some of that in
the
the trailer so that's that's all actual
gamepl
through the game are there certain
moments and levels where you can jump or
how do you play through that
yeah so in the game there is dimensional
damage spread throughout the galaxy that
ratchet and clank have to find a way to
fix
and you can find these weak points in
space-time
that you can pull to you with your rift
tether
it's like being able to lasso a portal
and that enables you to basically like
warp across the world
to find new places to discover or gain a
tactical advantage in combat
wow yeah i gotta say like when you see
that and you imagine the jumping from
multiple worlds
uh at at you know at instantaneously
almost and it sounds like there's no
load screens throughout the entire game
that's right we're going straight that's
right yep wow all right
so confident both of you say it i like
it um now
let me ask you about dual sense that's
something that is a big part of ps5 i've
had a chance
to control with the triggers and the
haptics um how are you using that for
to sort of impact the gameplay of rift
apart
so every ratchet and clank game is a
powerful arsenal
of weapons just exude a ton of
personality
and the dual sense is sort of like it
feels like it was made
for ratchet and clank just because the
haptics give us a whole new layer for
the weapons to express
themselves so for example your burst
pistol
of course it gives you like a satisfying
click or kick with every bullet
but when you throw the shatter bomb you
can actually feel
the energy pulsing off the grenade fade
away as it gets further apart from you
basically the haptics are expressive
enough that every weapon feels different
and you can tell what you're holding
but of course the adaptive trigger like
takes that to a functional level
where in addition to the trigger pull
feeling unique
we can actually use that as a super
intuitive way
to add alternate functions to the
weapons so
for example in the demo we've got the
enforcer which is a double-barreled
shotgun
you can pull the trigger part of the way
down until you hit resistance
to fire a single barrel and then
whenever you feel like it's the right
time pull it the rest of the way for a
double shot
so you might be swarmed by a bunch of
little enemies you only want to
waste one shot on them and then wait a
minute for even more to swarm in before
finishing them off
but a big guy you probably want to just
give both barrels to right away
so there's a nice intuitive way of
basically raising the skill ceiling
and giving you more ways to play better
wow no
i'm excited to see how you guys are
going to roll that out across what i'm
sure
are an insane uh you know group of
weapons as always uh
plot wise marcus tell us a bit about
this game i think some fans have
wondered you know does this tie into the
movie plot line the game plot line like
how it would tell us in the ratchet
verse where this sits
yeah well canonically this is a an
extension of
uh ratchet and clank um into the nexus
the 2013 game
but it's a standalone adventure so it's
one that
even if you've never played a ratchet
clan game you can get into it and you'll
understand it and you'll enjoy it
um for hardcore fans we have a lot of
nods you're gonna you're gonna see a lot
of returning characters and planets and
uh see them all through a whole new
light of multiple dimensionality
yeah no this this rift tether thing i
think looks really exciting and how
often
like is that something we saw in the
demo is that something you're going to
see like frequently in the game are
there special moments like i guess i'm
curious like how often you use that
technique for gameplay
so the the rift tether has created
these anomalies all throughout the
galaxy you'll encounter those pretty
often
there's even a few more types of
dimensional damage you'll encounter that
we haven't shown
yet now being pulled between worlds
that's that's localized to chasing after
dr nefarious in the demo um and that's
sort of reserved for special moments
when you really have to um
when the dimensional damage really tears
wide open
well i gotta say it looks incredible and
then at the end
we got another tease of uh this female
lombax uh i know you guys are confirmed
she is playable
in parts of the game i think everyone
wants to know though do we have a name
for her
i mean the world is more interesting
with mysteries and we're going to have
to keep this one
a little longer do we get a number of
letters in her name or anything
too many smart people on the internet
okay they'll figure it out right away
she's not named abby though right
all right we'll have to wait and see
what you guys have in store for us i
gotta say i mean it looks
incredible the ratchet games are always
so much fun and as you said when you
think of
the power of ssd and the dual sense all
coming together it looks really exciting
before we go though uh i think everyone
around the world
wants to know when we're going to get to
play this game
anything you can share with us on where
you're at in development right now
right mike
sriracha and clank is coming out in the
ps5
launch window so we haven't announced to
release a specific release date yet so
stay tuned for that
what kind of window is it big windows no
i'm just kidding all right that's all
we're gonna get i'm sure
ratchet and clank rift apart coming in
the launch window for playstation five i
gotta say uh
insomniac uh we're so excited what you
guys are doing across playstation
and uh the game looks incredible so
thank you so much for
all you've done and we look forward to
seeing more of riff to part soon
thanks jeff take care all right marcus
and mike from insomniac
thanks for showing us that first look at
ratchet and clank or playstation live
and that's going to do it
for opening night live thank you so much
for watching from around the world and
make sure to stay tuned all weekend
for more live gamescom coverage at
gamescom global
as for us we'll see you later this year
for the game awards 2020
our team is hard at work to build a very
special live show for you
coming in december we'll see you then
good night
[Music]
you